One.
Two was too bad.
Slavery in the house.
Ladies and gentleman,
how are you guys doing?
All right.
This is,
uh,
the Joe Rogan experience with our special guest,
Joe Coco Diaz,
Aka Mad Flavor Ata Planet Rock,
Aka Joey Karate.
Wow.
Hello.
If it's two in the afternoon and you ain't high,
go fuck yourself.
Go out of my face.
I want you around me like I want cancer,
my balls back.
And I'm saying you're going to come around here looking at me.
Where Yo fuck a wide eyes.
Pick him that you know I'm gonna be,
I'm gonna Reform.
Go Fuck Yourself.
My morning starts at 5:30 AM either you're there or your square.
You know what I'm saying?
Check this out.
The world famous banana bread baby.
There it is.
The for you people around the country.
What's the recipe?
I don't know the fuck recipe.
The recipe is that,
yeah.
I got a text from Brian in capital letters do not eat.
Joey Diaz is banana bread.
Nobody asked me that.
You still eat the banana bread?
I haven't even banana breadth is Yoshi.
Oh deed.
But before that,
the one day,
I hate the sliced and I was fucking driving home.
I didn't know where the fuck I was
eating the banana bread too.
I like to,
I go to the weed store and the guy goes,
uh,
we owe you a piece of banana bread.
So it has chocolate chips in it.
So if you,
if you're leaving the fucking car,
the chocolate chips on Melton.
I wasn't going home.
So here's the beauty of it.
I had a,
a soup attire.
Okay.
I had a meeting at CBS Radford.
So I hate the fucking thing.
And I,
my CBS,
oh,
the way,
the CBS,
I go,
let me eat the rest of this fucking fucking melt in my car driving.
I get to the fucking CBS told me for the lady and the guy,
and they're talking to me.
And while it's not talking to them,
it's fucking getting hot.
And I'm talking to them and they can tell something's wrong by Joe.
Are you okay with the lights on?
And I'm like,
yeah,
I'm alright.
And that pitch in this show and how it's going to be great.
You're going to be great for the show.
And I'm like,
this is going to be great,
but listen,
I got to go.
You don't when people want to talk,
but you got to go with it.
Right?
So for some reason I got in the car and there was so much traffic.
I went from Laurel Canyon Rafford the van eyes,
cause I couldn't make a right turn,
right?
Do you understand me guys as dirty years smoked the weed,
heroin every day.
I couldn't make a right turn.
I kept thinking that I was not go off a cliff.
So finally I can make the right turn and I'm taking my shirt off at this point.
At this point,
I'm down to a Guinea tee shirt.
The sunroof was open,
the windows are open,
I got the eblast and finally after we realize it's going to make a right,
there's a right channel.
Right now I'm driving on sheet number.
Finally,
I'm fucking hot and I need something to drink,
but I'm cutting stone to get out of the fucking car.
So what do I do?
I look in the backseat and there's an old water bottle that's probably 90
fucking degrees.
You know those hot water I pulled over and drag the,
Oh,
with that.
It gives you estrogen.
I don't give a fuck what it gives me with that though.
The coming out of my fucking four eggs yesterday,
my tits are getting home.
Get out of the car right there on chairman.
I just started puking and it's all gone.
Just chumps agreed.
Your body's broken.
Broken me.
I fucking said I got back in the car,
Lloyd,
if you get me home,
I've never been of the bread.
I'll never eat a fucking banana.
I'll never did go to the zoo.
I got home.
I ran upstairs.
I just lay on the couch naked on the,
I forget what my wife walked in and she's like,
Whoa,
what happened to you?
I go,
don't even ask.
She just,
she knew she could.
She keep fucking around with.
I see you back there.
He knew it was going to that you think about jelly.
Jelly was over my podcast.
Once we do with the podcast as a podcast started,
he just starts eating this cookie.
The body of Christ compels you.
I overdosed the other day.
Jeff heard what happened,
can eat that whole thing or you're fuck you fuck you to get that airway.
I'm scared.
I got nervous he'd be in a room with him cause I was just watching him take
chunks out of this fucking cookie.
They know I'm smelling the wheel.
This cookie.
I'm like this is chaos.
You're not supposed to eat a whole cookie.
Fuck that.
And he just keeps going and then an hour and 20 minutes later we're still doing
the podcasts and Shelly's gone.
There's no way.
No Joey know Joey's left.
Huh?
He's like dog.
I have no idea when we talking you can never eat edible marijuana it Joey Diaz
as you have thorazine on hand,
don't take that this,
you have a fucking and big hypodermic filled with adrenaline that you get stuff
into your chest up.
Joey Diaz gave me once,
gave me like some breath strips I guess is the first time I take him breath
strips and he was like,
eat two of these and I'm like,
I only took half of one of these knowing him and I was driving home on the
interstate and was like,
well,
it's definitely the apocalypse world is ending.
I see that clearly now there was a Mcdonald's,
but now he's going to stop my car and run to the Mcdonald's to get a burger.
He's traffic wasn't moving.
That's how bad the logic was working in my mind.
Anyway,
I get home,
I'm having the most terrible marijuana trip.
I'm laying in bed.
I'm like,
oh my God,
the world's in my heart's pounding.
Phone rings,
phone rings,
Joey Diaz,
I answer it.
He's like,
welcome to my house,
motherfucker.
We joked,
pulled his dick out as jealous.
This is what I got to tell this the first time.
That girl,
what's her?
That's what the function name,
the female comic.
All the ones that sued on Barris?
Yes.
What is her name?
Judy.
Okay,
so this is what happens.
She goes on to say,
we shouldn't have said her name,
she was on stage.
So she's,
she's on stage and she's not doing real well and we all barbecue now.
It was a small crowd.
So watches onstage,
Joey into the back area,
there's like this backstage area that's like in the,
or the O is a small room.
It only seats about a buck 50 but it does have a stage with a little backstage
area.
So Joey goes into the best day day.
Jerry,
he goes to the backstage area,
it takes off all his clothes and he waits.
And so she's doing her act and when she gets to our punchlines,
she hits the punchline and Joey opens the curtains and shakes his thick and then
closes them up real quick.
And the people go crazy.
And you see this spark in her eye,
like
working,
I'm finally doing it.
You could see a relax and every time she had a punchline,
jelly would pop open.
That curtain shakes day.
They close it and the people were fucking just stomping their feet,
laughing,
slapping their tables.
She had so much confidence in the next night.
You remember the last of the next time we saw her on stage and looked at the
same jokes,
just just didn't,
didn't work.
It was like
she had the magic cause she had it for one night.
But the weird thing is remember when Alison was on and we had talked about this
being a open mic comic and how a lot of these guys are doing these tricks and
one of the things that Allison was talking about is how this guy wanted her to
pay $100 in order to do five minutes in the belly ring belly room and she was
going to do that because she thought that's what you had to do to be an open mic
comic hundred dollars.
Yes.
Close.
You paid a hundred you're sucking my dick and give me a coat from Julie.
You think I'm fucking kidding you?
Fuck yeah,
you got to suck my Dick.
We got up in the bedroom and make a coffee that how many girls did you have to
do that?
All 20 of them.
I had this little blind open mic check.
God.
They used to come up to the commies low at 20 and just take me up to the belly
room was sucking my Dick,
then go do his set.
She was tremendous.
Then a year later she wrote me a letter to the comedy store.
You Cock sucker you.
I kept shooting sperm balls and they'll fucking,
he had bought,
I wouldn't have asked for $100 and blow jobs and legit,
that's known.
You know what I'm saying?
That's nose blow jobs.
$100 is bad cause right when you shoot it,
I am become death.
It's trotter over your belief by stuffing into thinking you're going to get on
stage.
I was like on a Friday night and she's like,
Joe,
you ain't know.
You know people get me and I looked her straight to the face as a joke and I go,
God,
you're going to have to sign.
I'm like,
no.
I said to,
I didn't even say something they could be.
I said,
I get you on stage and be to work.
And she goes,
what do you mean like a little put you to work after she got the,
you got to do something and she will look at me and goes,
I'm not really good at you have to teach me.
Oh you went back to our house and I told him at the house,
we had a great time,
but she had a period,
but I went to either ask you a tissue paper
and I just said,
keep sucking my dick.
I can't handle that muffler.
That point.
I'll get how fucked up.
I wouldn't need to get a little pussy if you had a period,
but I will.
I'll look.
Yes,
I'll just read the payment so I go whack off on your next up you have to say,
I got to look a little muffly just even get the party started and she had like a
little crumble like what it a dingleberry.
It's like somebody shot a spitball and it,
it just killed me dog.
I was like,
oh,
I can't even eat my dick it the whole night and I haven't come forward Gigas and
I can say Mark Babbitt pick me up like at eight in the morning.
No ma'am.
Did you get a good night's sleep?
Oh yeah,
sure.
Fuck,
I'm stuck.
I'm going to get my sticks second.
My boss Lik that's commonly stole one old one.
The old days Joe rode.
His uncle was the chief of police and that's who I used to run roll fags with.
The reason why we never got arrested was because the guy that was my base was
the chief's son when I was growing up.
We were both 1617 he was as good looking as Brad Pitt.
So that's what you do.
You put,
let's say,
what is this?
What is this over here?
Let's say Burbank Boulevard is where all the gay guys hang on.
I would take the best looking guy and go pro,
just standing up there for an hour.
We'll give you a piece of the action and just a salesman,
they pull up,
don't pull up one time and look at you.
They'll make a uturn.
They'll come back then don't make believe like they're looking for directions
and then they'll go,
you know what's going on?
And you're like,
no,
what are you going on?
I was looking for a date.
Well,
I was looking for a date for 100 bucks.
I'll suck your Dick.
So he would say,
I don't want to suck you into kind of the street.
Let me,
let me blow you into the park and the park.
We would be hiding in the tree.
So as soon as he went into the tree to get a dig site,
we fly out like a fucking superhero.
What happened?
I'll go onto that site.
It says,
just climb.
I'm over their head and take that boot.
So that shoes and that money and I got off,
have a or anyway,
yet nobody,
no.
So it was kind of fucking crazy.
Listen,
before I was driving,
I seen this kid,
Jewish kid with a Yamaka on walking around like a fucking Momo.
It's sandals on.
I almost pulled over and grabbing him by the shirt and said,
you're a fucking Jew.
You're a dumb fuck walking around and have some fucking bumpy one be dude
walking around like a fucking lumpy,
dumpy and not stop fucking move bodies that are racist.
Fucking crazy.
Yeah,
that.
Have you seen that picture of Daniel Day Lewis
Suck my state.
Go down a lot.
And you're making a movie about a who gives a fuck cut an apple tree or
something.
That's what you got to get back on.
But he's Mambos mine.
They don't like it does look exactly somewhere Zito from Miami vice
fuck gave Lincoln.
There's nothing wrong with my space and I'm gonna tell you why because in a year
it'll be back.
Yeah,
but you know it'll be back and then all you momos that got rid of your page or
you fucking moocs MIT sites.
The moment when we were hanging out at the Bray Improv and you did that fucking
bit about about dead Dick.
He goes,
you take two popsicle sticks,
new tie that tick up and you throw it back in like a wounded soldier and Joey
gimme your prognosis,
what's going to happen with this occupy Wall Street?
Well here it is.
First off,
we'll live in a fucking sixties just because you pimp up and time outside of my
fucking house with a tent.
I'm supposed to stop doing what I'm doing.
You got to go for you.
Gotta you gotta hit him with a fucking populace.
That shit with a tent.
That's as the fucking guy said in the Godfather.
That's Antigua.
If we're going against every fucking cooperation,
they're part of that.
We got to step up and live by it cause we've gotta set our marker and
unfortunate you think we have those no way.
These things and show these mother fuckers that we're not going to stand on wine
like donkeys.
That's what we've become as a boundary.
That's why we'll never move because we've become donkeys.
Fucking donkeys,
donkeys,
humans swim.
To avoid that Cuba swim 90 miles to avoid that feeling.
We've accepted standing like life is funny.
It's funny.
Joe Rogan was kind of put them in the store.
I've seen,
I get to the Mandalay.
I checked in the room as a comp under Joe Rogan's name.
He was very kind of the pay for it and the way up,
they checked my credit card and they gave me a slip and they sit on the way out.
You have to pay an extra $49 and I go for what?
It's a con and they go,
it's an association fee.
Listen,
I'll pay an association fee.
We'll,
I'll poke your fucking I app.
I'm not.
I told you when you get two free cocktails and I go ride the bike.
I couldn't even go to a spa.
I had to go ride the bike like a communist by myself.
I couldn't and I said to the lady,
I don't think
one of the biggest lessons I ever learned.
I never drank again on new years.
Never.
After I seen that one new years,
I went to a party like that.
It was very chill.
Everybody was having a good time unless I'm,
one of my buddies couldn't drink.
He started drinking and he started spitting on the floor.
People.
That person said something to him and he pulled like 200 hours in.
The person said something to him.
She was like,
really?
He goes,
either I'd take my money and leave.
Well,
fucking cause he started some shit and next thing you know,
all fight broke out.
That's the first time I flipped my ties.
Then he'd be on cooler bit my friend's ear off that night we had a drive to the
hospital.
It was a Baggie with icing and the bottom of his left ear lobe was in the thing
and he kept holding on to the close date.
As soon as I get stitched up,
I'm going to go back there and fuck him up.
It was one of those fights.
This motherfucker til this day won't give up.
You have to kill him with a stick,
but he was,
he was covered in blood.
They broke them up and he would say,
okay,
I'm already,
they'd say,
golf is shake daddy's hand.
He'd go over to Dan.
He said,
Daddy,
I'm sorry but your mother's still a car and let's go one more fucking time and
then they do it again for 20 minutes.
All right,
get me Laura and I'll start a,
Danny would go,
you're going to stop this time here.
There was,
it's a show showing them up here to go shake his hand.
Yeah,
it's old.
You know what?
Your mother still has read an or he's got his ear and a baggy with ice,
and he's like,
I hope this back to hurries up because I'm going to go back to his house and
knocked the fuck out of it,
but I never,
ever,
ever drag again.
I do use stay black cops,
other
big head.